OK, so let's start today with this video. This woman posted it on Facebook, saying that these girls, little girls, walked up to her on the street, and after talking to them for a while, she just knew she had to record them. Zoe Chace, one of the reporters at NPR's Planet Money , saw the video online, and she's the one you showed it to me.
好的，那我们就从这个视频开始今天的节目。一位女士把它发布在 Facebook 上，说这些小女孩在街上走向她，和她们聊了一会儿之后，她就知道自己必须把她们录下来。NPR 节目《Planet Money》的记者之一佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）在网上看到了这个视频，就是她把它展示给我的。
OK, so there's two little girls. They look to be about 10, 11-ish. They're in a parking lot, and the video opens, you don't see anybody, and then they run into the video, and they're right up in your face. And they are super cute.
好的，视频里有两个小女孩，看起来大概 10 岁、11 岁左右。她们在一个停车场里。视频刚开始时你还看不见人，然后她们跑进画面，直接凑到了镜头前，她们超级可爱。
Excuse me, ma'am. Hi, how are you?
不好意思，女士。嗨，你好吗？
I'm fine.  How are you?
我很好。你呢？
I'm fine, too. My name is Asia Newson. The name of my company is called--
我也很好。我叫亚希娅·纽森（Asia Newson）。我的公司名字叫——
(TOGETHER)  Super Business Girl. Our mission is to recognize the true potential in every child--
（合）超级商业女孩（Super Business Girl）。我们的使命是发掘每个孩子真正的潜力——
And to develop intrinsic security that makes optimum use of their individualized talent.
并培养内在的安全感，从而最大限度地利用他们个性化的天赋。
Yeah.
是的。
Pause it for a second. So the girl who's talking right now, she's wearing big black glasses, but do they have--
先暂停一下。说话的这个女孩戴着一副黑色大眼镜，但它们有——
No.
没有。
Lenses in them?
上面有镜片吗？
Those are not real glasses. That's just part of her thing. And she has this little gap between her teeth that she puts right up into the camera and grins at it.
那不是真正的眼镜。那只是她个人风格的一部分。她牙齿中间有个小缝，她直接对着镜头展示并咧嘴一笑。
Yeah. So let me break it down on an immensely biological basis. This awesome trainee right here is learning how to become a entrepreneur, how to make their own money and buy the things that they would need in their life.
是的。让我从极其生物学的角度来剖析一下。这位很棒的学员正在学习如何成为一名企业家，如何赚自己的钱，以及购买生活中需要的东西。
OK, so here she's gesturing at the other girl, the trainee, who's selling candles.
好的，她现在指着另一个女孩，那个卖蜡烛的学员。
Today I am selling some of my awesome candles, 'cause I'm raising money to buy my own school clothes and school supplies for the upcoming school year. Now I'm going to do a rap for you.
今天我在卖一些我很棒的蜡烛，因为我在攒钱买我下学年的校服和学习用品。现在我要为你表演一段说唱。
OK, now-- It's a lot of rhythm, see? Super Business Girl, Girl, Girl--
好了，现在——节奏感很强，看好了？超级商业女孩，女孩，女孩——
(TOGETHER)    Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl. Super Business Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl. Super Business Girl, Girl, Girl--
（合）女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩。超级商业女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩。超级商业女孩，女孩，女孩——
It gets in your head, actually, just the words "Super Business Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl." Like it gets in your head. It got into my head. And that is actually her company. Like, that is her branding. That is her selling her company, is just repeating the name of it again and again.
说真的，满脑子都是“超级商业女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩”这些词。就像它钻进了你的脑子里。它确实钻进了我的脑子。而这实际上就是她的公司。这就是她的品牌。她推销自己公司的方式就是一遍又一遍地重复它的名字。
(TOGETHER) Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl. Super Business Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl, Girl.
（合）女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩。超级商业女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩，女孩。
That's it.
就是这样。
Get it, girl.
干得漂亮，姑娘。
Bye.
再见。
So at this point in the video is when she actually really introduces the thing that she's selling, which is these candles that she makes. And she just sticks the candles right into the camera. She's like, "Smell 'em." That's it.
视频到这里时，她才真正介绍了她卖的东西，也就是她自己做的蜡烛。她直接把蜡烛戳到镜头前，说：“闻闻看。”就是这样。
So when Zoe saw this video, she watched it over and over, totally charmed by this kid. But also, as a business reporter, she had all kinds of questions.
所以当佐伊看到这个视频时，她反复看了好几遍，完全被这个孩子迷住了。但作为一名商业记者，她也有各种各样的问题。
Like who is she? Was this real? Is this, like, a one-off? Does she do this all the time? What is Super Business Girl? Like, is that a thing?
比如她是睡？这是真的吗？这只是一次性的吗？她经常这样做吗？什么是“超级商业女孩”？这算是个正经事吗？
So Zoe tracked her down. Her name is Asia Newson. She's 11. Super Business Girl is a thing. It's a website that sells candles.
于是佐伊找到了她。她叫亚希娅·纽森，11 岁。“超级商业女孩”确实是个正经事，那是一个销售蜡烛的网站。
Asia lives in West Detroit, but she happened to be coming to New York City to see her family that weekend, the one that Zoe called. And that also happens to be where Zoe lives. And I asked Zoe to play me the tape of their encounter, because our program today is all about business and the kinds of people who decide to go into business, and the kinds of people who succeed in business.
亚希娅住在底特律西区，但恰好那个周末她要去纽约看望家人，佐伊就是在那时候联系她的。而那也正好是佐伊住的地方。我让佐伊播放了她们见面的录音，因为我们今天的节目正是关于商业，以及那些决定投身商业的人，和那些在商业中取得成功的人。
So we meet up on 125th Street in Harlem. And basically as soon as we meet, she's-- she's with her dad, she's with her mom, she's with her cousin. And they just book it across the street to this deli.
我们在哈莱姆区的 125 街见面。基本上我们一见面——她和她爸爸、妈妈、表兄弟在一起。他们直接冲过马路去了那家熟食店。
We're going to get our product. I'm selling my lollipops. And I'm also selling my candles. But first I'm getting my lollipops.
我们要去拿我们的产品。我在卖我的棒棒糖，还有蜡烛。但首先我要去拿我的棒棒糖。
Now Asia usually sells candles back home in Detroit, but candles are heavy and hard to carry. So today in New York, they're going to sell lollipops. She buys them for $0.25 per Blow Pop and sells them for $1.
亚希娅平时在底特律老家卖蜡烛，但蜡烛很重，不好携带。所以今天在纽约，他们打算卖棒棒糖。她以每支 25 美分的价格买入 Blow Pop 棒棒糖，然后以 1 美元卖出。
It just-- it just makes sense to me. I won't have to spend so much on something, then I can sell it for more.
这对我来说——这完全讲得通。我不必花那么多钱买东西，然后我能以更高的价格卖出去。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
Making 300% profit.
获得 300% 的利润。
300% profit. So that's her business model. And she is so full of confidence that she basically walks right out of the deli, turns to the group of guys that are just kind of hanging out outside on the street corner, and makes the pitch to them.
300% 的利润。这就是她的商业模式。她充满了自信，基本上刚走出熟食店，就转向街角的一群人，直接向他们推销。
Excuse me, gentlemen. Hello, my name is Asia Newson. I'm known as Detroit's youngest entrepreneur. And the name of my company is called Super Business Girl. Today I'm selling lollipops because I'm raising money to buy my own school clothes--
不好意思，先生们。你好，我叫亚希娅·纽森。我是底特律最年轻的企业家。我的公司叫“超级商业女孩”。今天我卖棒棒糖，因为我在筹钱买我的校服——
Now of course, anybody who lives in a big city has been approached by kids-- you know, selling candy, asking for a couple bucks for it, saying it goes to their education or whatever. And Zoe's been approached, and all these guys have probably been approached. Zoe says this just feels different.
当然，任何住在在大城市的人都被孩子搭讪过——你知道，卖糖果，要几块钱，说是为了他们的教育什么的。佐伊也被搭讪过，这些男士可能也都被搭讪过。但佐伊说这感觉完全不同。
The way that Asia sells it is way less a sort of charity move than this kind of opportunity. Like, here I am. I am very special. You should pay attention to me. I am giving you a chance to invest in my future.
亚希娅的销售方式与其说是慈善，不如说是一种机会。就像是：我在这里，我非常特别，你应该关注我，我在给你一个投资我未来的机会。
And yeah, you can hear on the tapes, people are charmed. As Asia works her way down the street, going into crowded barbershops and hair salons, they are happy to give to her.
确实，你可以在录音里听到，人们被她迷住了。当亚希娅沿着街道，走进拥挤的理发店和美发沙龙时，人们都很乐意给她钱。
Because you'll make a difference in my life. Thank you for listening to my presentation.
因为你会对我的生活产生影响。谢谢你听我的演讲。
That was beautiful. That was beautiful. How much?
太棒了。这太棒了。多少钱？
Well, I'm only asking for $1 investment, because you'll make a strong strong impact to my education.
嗯，我只请求 1 美元的投资，因为你将对我的教育产生强有力的影响。
I will?
我会吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS] You're beautiful, sugar. She's a sweetheart.
（笑）你真漂亮，甜心。她真是个可爱的小姑娘。
Oh, well, thank you for the lollipop.
噢，谢谢你的棒棒糖。
Thank you. I hope you have an awesome day.
谢谢。希望你有美好的一天。
And I hope you have a blessed one as well, sweetie. I'm loving you! [LAUGHS]
也希望你有一个被祝福的一天，亲爱的。我爱你！[笑]
Why'd you buy it?
你为什么买它？
Why did I buy it? To support her.
我为什么买它？为了支持她。
Why?
为什么？
It's a good cause. She's just very outspoken, very outgoing. Good personality.
这是一个好的事业。她非常直率，非常外向，性格很好。
The number-one thing is give energy. Two, speak very loud, be articulate, use hand gestures, and make eye contact.
最重要的一点是给予能量。第二，说话声音要大，吐字清晰，多用手势，并进行眼神交流。
Now this is what Asia tells other kids to do when she trains them. But of course, that is like somebody who's always been skinny giving advice to people on how to diet. This stuff just comes easily to her.
这就是亚希娅训练其他孩子时教的内容。但当然，这就像一个一直很瘦的人在教别人如何节食。这些东西对她来说是与生俱来的。
It is a hard thing to teach. I saw her try to make her cousin do this pitch, who was with her, and he just couldn't handle it.
这很难教。我看到她试着让她表弟做这个推销，但他完全搞不定。
What happened when her cousin tried?
她表弟尝试时发生了什么？
Um, people wouldn't really respond to him, because he was kind of looking down. He wasn't really looking at people.
嗯，人们并没有什么回应，因为他有点低着头，没有真正看着人们。
Oh, he was a kid.
噢，毕竟是个孩子。
He-- yeah!
他——是的！
[BOTH LAUGH]
（两人笑）
He was a regular kid. He was a kid that was 10 years old and, like, embarrassed to be talking to adults.
他是个普通孩子。他是个 10 岁、对和成年人说话感到尴尬的孩子。
At this point, Asia has an office in a business incubator place in Detroit. She gets mentorship there, she gets classes. This, by the way, is an adult business incubator, where she is the only kid.  Everybody else is grown up.
目前，亚希娅在底特律的一个商业孵化器里有间办公室。她在那里接受指导、上课。顺便说一下，那是一个成人商业孵化器，她是唯一的孩子。其他所有人都是成年人。
Her dad is a salesman. And he's very involved in what Asia does, which Zoe says can be a little unsettling to watch, seeing an adult stage-parent their kid this way. Though she says that Asia is so clearly into what she is doing, it really does not feel bad to watch it. It's like watching a stage parent whose kid totally loves being on stage. And for Zoe, as a business reporter, what was interesting about Asia was her instinctive comprehension of a basic business principle-- a principle that some adults don't always seem to grasp.
她爸爸是个推销员，也非常参与亚希娅所做的一切。佐伊说看到一个成年人这样操纵孩子可能会让人有点不安。尽管她说，很明显亚希娅非常喜欢她正在做的事情，这看起来并不让人反感。就像看着一个虎妈，而她的孩子完全热爱舞台一样。对于佐伊这位商业记者来说，亚希娅最有趣的地方在于她对基本商业原则的直觉理解——一个有时连成年人都无法领会的原则。
She has this kind of sophisticated understanding, it seems like, that people are just excited to invest in other people. Like it has really nothing to do with what Asia is selling, you know? Asia's selling Blow Pops that nobody wants. It's so obvious that she knows that she's just selling Asia.
她似乎有一种复杂的理解，人们只是乐于投资他人。这真的和亚希娅卖什么毫无关系，你知道吗？亚希娅卖的是没人想要的 Blow Pops。很明显，她知道她推销的其实就是她自己。
And this is not something that all people that are making pitches to investors or customers or whatever get. Like, a lot of people are kind of nerds, and they're like, "This is my product. This is my platform. I built this app, or whatever it is, and I want people--"
而这并不是所有向投资者或客户推销的人都能意识到的。很多人有点书呆子气，他们会说：“这是我的产品，这是我的平台。我构建了这个应用，等等，我想要人们——”
Right. They think the thing will speak on its merits. They have a great product.
对，他们认为产品本身会说话。他们有很棒的产品。
Yeah, or that the idea is so special. But they don't realize that people connect to other people. But Asia knows this.
是的，或者认为这个想法非常特别。但他们没有意识到人们是与他人建立联系的。但亚希娅知道这一点。
Do you think that you're selling more, like, you're selling, you know--
你觉得你是在卖——你是说，你卖的是——
More of myself and my services than my product? Yeah, I do. Or was that not what you were going to say? People ask me that question all the time.
卖的是我自己和我的服务，多过我的产品？是的，我是这么认为的。或者那不是你想问的？人们一直问我这个问题。
Yeah, that's what I was gonna ask.
是的，我本来就是想问这个。
That's what I thought.
我就是这么想的。
I wasn't even there yet with my question. I was trying to tease this thing out of her the way you do, especially if it's a little kid. But she already knows. She already knows what she is.
我还没问到那儿呢。我本来想像对待小孩子那样慢慢引导她说出来，但她已经知道了。她已经知道她自己是什么了。
I was a cute girl who knew about business and who liked what I did.
我是一个懂得商业且喜欢自己所做之事的可爱女孩。
So you know that you're cute.
所以你知道你很可爱。
Yeah.
是的。
And how do you use the being cute in your business?
你是如何利用可爱在你的生意中的？
[GIGGLES] Um-- [GIGGLES] I just act like me. I'm a little girl running my own business. That's the best advantage ever. But I'm 11 now, so as I'm getting older, it's kind of going away a little bit, which makes it a little harder for me to sell my candles and my suckers.
（咯咯笑）嗯——（咯咯笑）我只是做我自己。我是一个经营自己生意的女孩。那是最好的优势。但我现在 11 岁了，随着我长大，这种优势正在逐渐消失，这让推销蜡烛和棒棒糖变得有点困难了。
Oh, no! She's getting older and she's losing it at 11?
噢，不！她 11 岁就开始觉得自己不再可爱了吗？
(LAUGHING)  Yeah. She knows that she's not gonna be cute forever.
（笑）是的。她知道她不可能永远可爱下去。
Wait, wait, wait, did she make more money when she was littler?
等等，等等，她小时候赚的钱更多吗？
(LAUGHING)  Yeah. She remembers being five and making a sales pitch, and people were more excited to give her money the littler she was.
（笑）是的。她记得五岁时做推销，她越小，人们给钱就越兴奋。
Luckily as she ages, she also has charisma, mentors, and plans-- big, big plans. And today on our radio show, "It's Not the Product, It is the Person," we have stories of adults who do not always seem to understand that idea as well as this 11-year-old girl does. And also of adults who do understand that they're the product, and they are struggling to live up to the job of being the product.
幸运的是，随着年龄增长，她还有个人魅力、导师和计划——非常宏大的计划。今天在我们的广播节目《不是产品，是人》中，我们将分享一些成年人的故事，他们似乎并不像这个 11 岁的女孩那样理解这一理念。还有些人理解自己就是产品，但他们却在努力维持这种身为“产品”的工作。
Just think for a second-- how does it make you feel when you know you are the product and the world is deciding not to buy? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
试想一下——当你明知自己是产品而世界决定不买账时，那是什么感觉？来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "I Got 99 Problems and a Pitch is One." So here's a thought that's got a lot of people into a lot of trouble-- the thought, "I can do that." I can land that skateboard trick. I can start my own band. I think I want to open a bookstore. You know, I've always loved books. I could own a bookstore. There's just that moment when you go from observer to doer, can be very, very treacherous.
第一幕，“我有 99 个问题，推销是其中之一”。人们经常陷入一个麻烦的想法：“我能做到”。我能完成那个滑板技巧。我能组建自己的乐队。我想开一家书店。你知道，我一直喜欢书，我能拥有书店。当你从旁观者变成实干家时，那一刻可能会非常、非常危险。
Well, This American Life producer Alex Blumberg is in the middle of this moment right now, an extreme version of this moment. For several years now, Alex has been running Planet Money . That's the podcast about economics and business that Zoe Chace works for, who you heard just a minute ago.
《美国生活》的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）现在正处于这一时刻，这是一个极端版本。几年来，亚历克斯一直在运营《Planet Money》。也就是佐伊·蔡斯所在的那个关于经济和商业的播客。
Recently, Alex quit that gig at Planet Money . He stopped reporting on other people's businesses, and he decided to start his own business instead. And he started recording the process of making a new business with his audio gear, because although he really doesn't know much about running a business, he knows a lot about recording conversations, and he felt like he needed something to feel good about. He has this true account of one man's journey from man to businessman.
最近，亚历克斯辞去了《Planet Money》的工作。他不再报道别人的生意，而是决定自己创业。他用音频设备记录下了创业的全过程，因为虽然他对经营生意了解不多，但他非常擅长记录谈话，而且他觉得需要一些让自己感觉良好的事。这是一个人从平凡人走向企业家的真实记录。
One of the great things about reporting on yourself? All the access you get. As a business reporter reporting on myself as a businessman, I would be privy to all this behind-the-scenes stuff that most businesspeople never, ever talk to reporters about.
报道自己的一大好处是什么？你能获得所有的权限。作为一名报道自己的商业记者，我能接触到大多数商业人士绝不会告诉记者的幕后事。
For example, this detail. When you're going out to do something you've never done before-- meet an investor at a venture capital firm and try to convince him to give you money to start your company-- what do you wear? Suit and tie? Tech golf-shirt casual? I was on my way out the door, and my wife Nazanin stopped me and told me to change my shoes.
比如这个细节：当你准备去做一件从未做过的事情——去风险投资公司见投资者，并试图说服他给你钱创业时——你穿什么？西装革履？科技公司的休闲高尔夫衫？我正要出门时，我妻子纳扎宁（Nazanin）拦住我，让我换鞋。
They're fine. They're just-- there'd be a higher chance that he's going to give you money if you're not wearing running shoes. Don't you think that's true?
它们挺好的。只是——如果你不穿跑鞋的话，他给你钱的机会会更大。你不觉得吗？
But these are the only shoes that I can wear that my feet don't hurt in. [LAUGHS]
但这是我穿起来脚不痛的唯一一双鞋了。（笑）
Um.
嗯。
Like a lot of conversations between married people, what we're talking about is not actually what we're talking about. Here's what we're actually talking about. We have a two-year-old and a four-year-old. My wife has a demanding job where she works till 11 o'clock most nights a week. I'm leaving a full-time job with a good salary and benefits for an uncertain future.
就像很多已婚夫妇的谈话一样，我们谈论的实际上并不是我们正在谈论的内容。我们实际在讨论的是：我们有一个两岁和一个四岁的孩子。我妻子有一份高要求的工作，每周大部分晚上要工作到 11 点。我正要放弃一份薪水丰厚、福利完善的全职工作，去迎接一个不确定的未来。
Our plan, if you can call it that, is to spend down our meager savings, go into debt, and hope it works out. I have a lot of anxiety. Nazanin has a lot of anxiety-- which is all focused, at this moment, on which shoes I should wear.
我们的计划——如果这算计划的话——就是花光我们微薄的积蓄，负债，然后希望一切顺利。我有很多焦虑。纳扎宁也有很多焦虑——而在这一刻，所有的焦虑都集中在：我该穿哪双鞋。
I don't know. You think these look better? Not sure they look better. I think these look like nursing shoes.
我不知道。你觉得这双好看吗？不确定它们是否更好。我觉得它们看起来像护士穿的鞋。
Why did you buy them?
你为什么买它们？
To play tennis in. [LAUGHS]
为了打网球。（笑）
Oh, they're like actual tennis shoes.
噢，它们是真正的网球鞋啊。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, OK. Then, yeah, wear the other ones.
噢，好的。那好吧，穿另外一双吧。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
There are over 28 million businesses in America. And I imagine they almost all started the way mine is-- with nothing but a story, a story I'm telling not just to my investors, but to my wife and to myself. That story that I'm telling, that we all probably tell, I'm the guy in the garage with the great idea. I am Steve Jobs.
美国有超过 2800 万家企业。我想它们几乎都是这样开始的——只有故事，一个我不仅告诉投资者，也告诉妻子和自己的故事。那个故事我们可能都讲过：我是车库里有绝妙想法的家伙。我是史蒂夫·乔布斯。
Just not the actual Steve Jobs, of course. I am the Steve Jobs of HVAC repair, or the Steve Jobs of farm-to-table gastropubs. Or, in my case, the Steve Jobs of 20- to 40-minute weekly podcasts.
当然，不是真正的史蒂夫·乔布斯。我是 HVAC（暖通空调）维修界的乔布斯，或是从农场到餐桌的餐厅界的乔布斯。或者，以我为例，我是 20 到 40 分钟每周播客界的乔布斯。
That is my business. I love podcasts. I want more of them. I looked around and there didn't seem to be anybody, inside or outside of public radio, devoted to making the kind of podcasts that I love. And then came the other thought. "Well, I could do that."
这就是我的生意。我热爱播客。我想要更多。我环顾四周，似乎无论是公共广播内部还是外部，都没有人致力于制作我喜欢的这类播客。然后那个念头又来了：“好吧，我能做到。”
The story, though, that we tell ourselves is a lie. Most of us are, in fact, not even close to being Steve Jobs. Of the hundreds of thousands of businesses that start every year, only 3 in 10 survive out the decade.
然而，我们告诉自己的故事是个谎言。事实上，我们大多数人甚至连成为史蒂夫·乔布斯的边都沾不上。每年创办的数十万家企业中，只有 30% 能存活超过十年。
Chris?
克里斯？
How are you?
你好吗？
Hey, how's it going?
嘿，怎么样？
Good, good, good.
很好，很好。
Thanks for meeting me.
谢谢你跟我见面。
It's Friday, lunch, mid-spring, and I'm at a hole-in-the-wall sushi place on Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles. I've flown out here from my home in New York to meet a guy named Chris Sacca. Chris is the kind of guy that people like me need to sell our story to. He's a professional investor.
周五，午餐时间，春季中期，我在洛杉矶 Pico 大道一家不起眼的寿司店。我从纽约家里飞过来见一个叫克里斯·萨卡（Chris Sacca）的人。克里斯就是像我这样的人需要推销故事的对象。他是一位专业投资者。
Now before I was in public radio, I was a teacher, and before that, a social worker. I've worked in nonprofits my entire life. If I actually start this business, CEO of my own company will be the first full-time job in the private sector I've ever had. All this to say, Chris Sacca and I traditionally run in different circles.
在加入公共广播之前，我是一名老师，再之前是社会工作者。我一生都在非营利组织工作。如果我真的创办了这家公司，担任自己公司的首席执行官将是我第一份私营部门的全职工作。简而言之，克里斯·萨卡和我传统上属于不同的圈子。
But this is where covering business helps. I met Chris on a Planet Money story I worked on about the patent system and how it seemed to be slowing innovation in Silicon Valley. Chris had a lot to say on the subject, so I ended up talking to him for a while.
但这就是商业报道有所帮助的地方。我在《Planet Money》一篇关于专利制度的文章中遇到了克里斯，那个制度似乎正在减缓硅谷的创新。克里斯对这个话题有很多看法，所以我和他聊了很久。
Years later, when I was starting this company, I reached out to him about being an investor. Honestly, he was one of the only people I knew who did this for a living, invested in stuff. And he remembered me. Turns out he's a fan of This American Life . And so he said, "Sure. Come on out. We'll talk."
多年后，当我创办这家公司时，我联系了他，询问他是否愿意投资。老实说，他是我认识的极少数以此为生、投资项目的人之一。他记得我。原来他是《美国生活》的粉丝。所以他说：“当然。过来吧，我们聊聊。”
Now I knew that Chris was successful, but I didn't realize exactly how successful until this lunch. One of Chris's first investments as an independent investor was in a company a former colleague of his at Google was starting. The colleague's name? Evan Williams. The company? Twitter. Evan showed Chris an early prototype of the idea.
我知道克里斯很成功，但直到这顿午餐我才意识到他到底有多成功。克里斯作为独立投资者的第一笔投资，是投给他在谷歌的前同事创办的一家公司。同事的名字叫埃文·威廉姆斯（Evan Williams）。公司名叫 Twitter。埃文向克里斯展示了这个想法的早期原型。
It was compelling, and a little bit addictive, and released dopamine every time your phone buzzed with a new tweet. And it played on a little bit of narcissism and exhibitionism and exploration-- all these things were happening that were pretty exciting. And so when Ev gave me the chance to invest in that company, I found it irresistible.
它引人入胜，还有点让人上瘾，每次你的手机因为新推文响起时，它就会释放多巴胺。它利用了人们的一点自恋、表演欲和探索欲——所有这些事情同时发生，非常令人兴奋。所以当 Ev 给我机会投资那家公司时，我觉得无法抗拒。
He wrote a check for $25,000, which he probably had no business doing. He had a little money, sure, but $25,000 was still a lot of cash to him. Unlike the majority of investors in Silicon Valley, who Chris says can break off a check for $25,000 like it's nothing, he really needed his bet to pay off. So he just started showing up at the headquarters of Twitter, trying to help out however he could.
他写了一张 2.5 万美元的支票，他当时可能根本不该这么做。他确实有一点钱，但对当时的克里斯来说，2.5 万美元仍然是一大笔钱。与硅谷大多数投资者不同——他们开出 2.5 万美元支票就像没事人一样——克里斯真的需要这笔赌注获得回报。所以他开始频繁出现在 Twitter 总部，尽其所能提供帮助。
To say that this gamble paid off is an understatement. Chris Sacca wouldn't say exactly how much he personally owns of Twitter, but at the time of Twitter's IPO, his venture fund was the single largest shareholder in the company, with a stake of roughly 15%. For Chris, what started as a single $25,000 investment is now a stake worth hundreds of millions of dollars.
说这次赌博获得了回报简直是轻描淡写。克里斯·萨卡没透露他个人具体拥有多少 Twitter 的股份，但在 Twitter IPO 时，他的风险基金是该公司最大的单一股东，持股比例约为 15%。对克里斯来说，起初那笔 2.5 万美元的投资，现在变成了价值数亿美元的股份。
Now one Twitter in your portfolio is something any investor would dream of. Chris has a lot more than one. Kickstarter, Instagram, Uber-- he was an early investor in all of them. And he's developed something of a philosophy for successful investing. Sure, you evaluate the idea, you look at the numbers, kick the tires-- that's all important. But, he says, he also looks hard at the conviction of the people who are pitching him.
投资组合中有一个 Twitter 是任何投资者梦寐以求的。克里斯拥有的不仅仅这一个。Kickstarter、Instagram、Uber——他是所有这些公司的早期投资者。他形成了一种成功的投资哲学。当然，你评估想法，看数据，进行尽职调查——这都很重要。但他表示，他也非常看重向他推销的人的信念。
The ideas that we back and the entrepreneurs we back, there's so much conviction about the inevitability of success, it's contagious. I mean, when I first sat down with Kevin Systrom, the founder of Instagram, and he started talking about why Instagram, and pitching me on why I should get involved there, I sat down with, in the back of my mind, look, photo-sharing has been done a bunch of times. I feel lucky to have already gotten some money back out of Photobucket before. Like, I might be the one guy who's made money in photo-sharing, and there's no way lightning's going to strike twice.
我们支持的想法和创业者，他们对成功的必然性有着如此强烈的信念，这具有传染性。我的意思是，当我第一次与 Instagram 的创始人凯文·斯特罗姆（Kevin Systrom）坐下来时，他开始谈论为什么要做 Instagram，推销我为什么应该加入。我当时心想：嘿，照片分享已经被做过很多次了。我觉得自己能从 Photobucket 那里拿回一些钱已经很幸运了。我可能是唯一一个在照片分享上赚到钱的人，绝不可能有第二次好运。
But as you listen to him, you get the perception that he's actually looking through you to some spot behind you that's five years in the future. And he just knows the inevitability of the success of his platform. And by the end of the conversation, you're like, please take my money. So what starts as this, like, all right, kid, what-- whaddaya got? It's just, like, wow, let me get on this thing. The train is leaving the station.
但当你听他说话时，你会有一种感觉，他仿佛透过你看向五年后的未来。他知道他的平台注定会成功。到谈话结束时，你会想：请拿走我的钱吧。所以起初那种“好吧，孩子，你有什么？”的态度，变成了“哇，让我加入吧，列车要出发了。”
This was thrilling to hear, because that conviction, I actually feel it. And conviction, in general, is a pretty rare feeling for me. I'm much more intimate with doubt and ambivalence.
听到这些令人兴奋，因为那种信念，我确实感受到了。而且，总的来说，信念对我来说是一种相当罕见的感觉。我更熟悉的是怀疑和矛盾。
And Chris is like a teacher handing me the answers to a test he's about to give, explaining exactly what he wants to see from me in order to invest in my company. I need to project conviction. Check. And I need to instill FOMO. For you non-Millennials, FOMO is an acronym-- Fear Of Missing Out.
克里斯就像老师把即将到来的考试答案递给我，明确解释他想从我身上看到什么才能投资我的公司。我需要展现信念。打钩。我还需要灌输 FOMO。对于非千禧一代，FOMO 是一个缩写——错失恐惧症（Fear Of Missing Out）。
Airbnb, multi-billion-dollar business, right? I was one of the first people to see the Airbnb page. And I pulled them aside and said, guys, this is super dangerous. You're renting out a room in somebody's house while they're still there? Somebody's going to get raped or murdered, and the blood is gonna be on your hands. There's no way this'll succeed. That's a $10 billion business today that I'm not an investor in.
Airbnb，数十亿美元的公司，对吧？我是最早看到 Airbnb 页面的人之一。我把他们拉到一边说，伙计们，这太危险了。你们在别人还在家的时候出租房间？一定会有人被强奸或杀害，你们手上有血。这绝不可能成功。今天那是家 100 亿美元的公司，而我不是投资者。
Dropbox. I saw the Dropbox guys, and I was like, this is great and everything, but Google's going to crush you. They have a thing internally called G-Drive, and it's going to absolutely crush Dropbox. There's no way this thing's going to succeed. That's a $10 billion business today that I'm not an investor in.
Dropbox。我见过 Dropbox 的团队，我当时说，这很好，但谷歌会摧毁你们。他们内部有一个叫 G-Drive 的东西，它会绝对粉碎 Dropbox。这绝不可能成功。今天那是家 100 亿美元的公司，而我不是投资者。
"A $10 billion business that I'm not an investor in"? That is FOMO. Once you have FOMO on your side, says Chris, you no longer have to ask people like him for money. They're lining up to give it to you.
“一家 100 亿美元的公司，而我不是投资者”？这就是 FOMO。克里斯说，一旦你有了 FOMO 在手，你就不用再向他这样的人乞求资金了，他们会排着队给你钱。
So I'd traveled out to see Chris Sacca with what's called a pitch deck, which is basically a PowerPoint on a laptop telling the story of what my company is going to do and how it's going to make money. Not surprisingly, you can read a lot on the internet about how to make a killer pitch deck. And like screenplays, pitch decks are supposed to follow a standard three-act structure. What's the problem out there? How is my company going to solve that problem? And how is solving that problem going to make huge amounts of money for everyone?
所以我带着所谓的“推销演示文稿”（pitch deck）去见克里斯·萨卡，那基本上是笔记本电脑上的 PowerPoint，讲述我的公司要做什么以及如何赚钱。不出所料，你可以在网上读到很多关于如何制作杀手级演示文稿的信息。就像剧本一样，演示文稿应该遵循标准的三幕结构。市场上有什么问题？我的公司如何解决该问题？以及解决该问题如何为每个人带来巨额利润？
And usually there's a conference room, maybe even a large-screen monitor, where you plug your computer into, show your PowerPoint. But after lunch, Chris says, OK, let's take a walk. You can give me your pitch. And that's how it came to pass that right there on the sidewalk along West Pico Boulevard, I made my pitch to Chris Sacca.
通常会有会议室，甚至大屏幕显示器，你可以把电脑插上，展示你的 PowerPoint。但午餐后，克里斯说：“好的，我们去走走，你可以给我推销一下。”就这样，就在西 Pico 大道的人行道上，我向克里斯·萨卡推销了。
Well, I have a deck which I, like-- which, I've used with people.
嗯，我有个演示文稿，我——我和别人用过。
Yeah, yeah, the deck is a crutch.
是啊，是啊，演示文稿是个拐杖。
It was a crutch. I got used to it. All right, so what's my-- yeah. So--
它确实是个拐杖。我习惯它了。好吧，那么我的——好吧。那么——
Pretty much immediately, all the confidence that I felt during the lunch evaporates. Remember the structure, Blumberg, I tell myself. Problem, solution, money.
几乎立刻，我在午餐时感受到的自信全消失了。记住结构，布隆伯格，我告诉自己。问题，解决方案，钱。
Here's the problem. In the world of audio right now, most people consume-- the kind of audiojournalism that I do, most people consume it over the radio. Those people are leaving the radio in droves, and they're migrating to digital. They're migrating to digital listening.
问题在于：在音频世界中，现在大多数人消费——我做的这种音频新闻，大多数人是通过广播消费的。这些人正在成群结队地离开广播，转向数字领域。他们正在向数字收听迁移。
The number of, obviously, smartphone handsets are going through the roof. The audio dashboard is becoming digital. iTunes Radio, podcasting is all going to be on your dashboard. And there's this whole world of-- so there's all these people going there, and so I want to start a company that will create the content for all these people to listen to, who are, like, moving into the digital future-slash-present.
智能手机听筒的数量显然在飙升。音频控制面板正在数字化。iTunes Radio、播客都将出现在你的面板上。有这样一个世界——所有人都在往那里走，所以我想创办一家公司，为所有这些转向数字未来——或者说现在——的人创作内容。
"Digital future-slash-present"? Who says that? It is so hard to listen back to this tape and hear myself dropping out this jargon, talking about listening to the radio as "consuming audio." I just sound like such a jerk. I sound like such a poser. And notice, the more nervous I become, the higher my voice gets.
“数字未来或者现在”？谁会那么说？回听这段录音，听到自己在那儿掉书袋、把听广播称为“消费音频”，真是太难受了。我听起来就像个混蛋，听起来就像个装模作样的人。而且要注意，我越紧张，声音越高。
So you-- you're uniquely positioned to do it because you're better at it than anybody?
所以你——你处于独特的地位去做这件事，因为你比任何人都擅长？
Yeah. I am.
是的。我是。
Don't apologize for that.
别为此道歉。
I'm doing so badly that Chris is now stepping in and feeding me lines. One question, he asked. What is my unfair advantage?
我做得太差了，克里斯现在开始介入并喂我台词。他问了一个问题：我的不公平竞争优势是什么？
I knew this was a critical question, but I had no idea how to answer it. Not only do I sound like a poser, I'm the wrong kind of poser. I'm not even doing it well. Still, I sallied forth.
我知道这是一个关键问题，但我完全不知道怎么回答。我不仅听起来像个装模作样的人，而且是那种不对路的。我甚至都没装好。尽管如此，我还是硬着头皮上了。
I explained to Chris my plan on how to make money-- ads, of course-- with a second main revenue source-- you guys, listeners. Not that we would charge for podcasts, but for those of you who don't obsessively read everything written about the future of media, there's this concept called freemium.
我向克里斯解释了我赚钱的计划——当然是广告——还有第二个主要收入来源——你们，听众。不是说我们要对播客收费，但对于那些不执着于阅读所有关于媒体未来内容的人来说，有一个叫“免费增值”（freemium）的概念。
It basically means you make your stuff for free, and then you offer a little something extra that some percentage of your listeners will pay for. One time we did this on Planet Money, sold $600,000 worth of T-shirts. That's how I explain it now. Here's how I explained it to Chris in the language of Poser.
它基本意味着你免费提供内容，然后提供一点额外的东西，一小部分听众会为此付费。有一次我们在《Planet Money》做了这件事，卖出了价值 60 万美元的 T 恤。我就是这么解释的。这是我以“装模作样”的语言向克里斯解释的方式。
And I believe there is a huge opportunity in audio, specifically, to really do the thing that all media's dreaming of doing, which is making this-- making this freemium model work.
我相信在音频领域有一个巨大的机会，真正去做所有媒体都梦想做的事情，也就是让这个——让这个免费增值模式运作起来。
And I watched Chris Sacca's face cycle from bored to confused to annoyed, I realized despite being given the answers to this test ahead of time, I'm still somehow failing. I am generating no FOMO in Chris Sacca's heart. If anything, I'm generating the opposite.
看着克里斯·萨卡的脸从无聊转为困惑再转为厌烦，我意识到尽管提前拿到了考试答案，我还是失败了。我没能在克里斯·萨卡心中激起任何 FOMO。如果有的话，我激起的是反向效果。
You gotta tighten up your story.
你得精简你的故事。
So the--
所以——
Well, start again. So you've now kind of meandered. Really tight this time. How are you going to make money doing this?
好吧，从头开始。你刚才有点东拉西扯。这次一定要精简。你打算怎么通过做这个赚钱？
So you make money a combination-- so there's three major-- there's three major revenue streams.
所以你通过一个组合赚钱——所以有三个主要的——有三个主要的收入流。
I start again. I meander my way through the ad rates, Planet Money . At a certain point I find myself deep into an explanation of my friend's successful Kickstarter project. Chris interrupted.
我重新开始。我一路东拉西扯地解释《Planet Money》的广告费率。在某个时候，我发现自己深入到了对我朋友成功的 Kickstarter 项目的解释中。克里斯打断了。
You lost track of your own outline.
你丢失了你自己的大纲。
Yeah, I did.
是的，我确实丢了。
What you haven't given me is the outline of your story, right?
你没给我的是你故事的大纲，对吧？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
If I were calling an Uber right now and it said it's going to be here in two minutes, and that was all the time you had--
如果我现在叫了辆 Uber，显示两分钟后到达，而那就是你拥有的所有时间——
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
What are you doing?
你会怎么做？
So I'm making a network of digital podcasts that we will mon-- that will-- that will-- that is going to meet-- [LAUGHS] Sorry.
所以我正在制作一个数字播客网络，我们将监——那将——那将——那将会满足——（笑）抱歉。
I'm imagining the people out there listening right now who actually know who Chris Sacca is. I didn't realize his reputation when I first arranged to meet him. I thought he was just a rich guy in Silicon Valley.
我正在想象那些正在听的、确实知道克里斯·萨卡是谁的人。我第一次安排见他时，并没有意识到他的名气。我以为他只是硅谷的一个有钱人。
But after enough conversations with people who were like, you're meeting with Chris Sacca? I realized that in this world, he is this huge kingpin. Not a murderous criminal-underworld kingpin-- a universally admired, really friendly billionaire kingpin that pretty much everybody with a startup idea wants as an investor. In other words, this walk we're taking along Pico Boulevard? Thousands of people would kill for this opportunity. And I'm blowing it.
但在与人聊过几次，对方问“你在见克里斯·萨卡？”之后，我意识到在这个世界里，他是如此巨大的头目。不是那种杀人犯式的地下头目——而是一个全球受人尊敬、非常友好的亿万富翁头目，几乎所有有创业想法的人都想让他成为投资者。换句话说，我们在 Pico 大道上走的这段路？成千上万的人会为这个机会杀人。而我却搞砸了。
At a certain point, Chris drops the pretense that this is an actual investor meeting and just starts coaching me on my pitch, feeding me questions, and then correcting my answers.
在某个时候，克里斯丢掉了这是正式投资者会议的假象，开始辅导我的推销，给我抛出问题，然后纠正我的答案。
And so what's it going to take to do it?
那么，要做这件事需要什么？
So it'll take a million and a half dollars, I think. And--
所以我想需要 150 万美元。然后——
Take out the "I think."
去掉“我想”。
Yeah. It'll take a million and a half-- I'm looking for a million and a half to $2 million in seed-stage funding.
是的。需要 150 万——我正在寻找 150 万到 200 万美元的种子轮资金。
No, no, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不，不。
Yeah.
是的。
You were looking for a very specific amount of money.
你在寻找一个非常具体的金额。
I'm looking for-- [LAUGHS NERVOUSLY]
我正在寻找——（紧张地笑）
Finally, after about an hour of this, I look over and see Chris holding up his hand.
终于，在进行了大约一个小时这样的训练后，我看到克里斯举起手。
Give me a second and I'm gonna give you your pitch back.
给我一秒钟，我会把推销语还给你。
All right.
好的。
But let me write--
但让我写——
And then, right there, not far from the freeway overpass near Pico and Bundy, he steps into the role of me, starts giving the pitch I should be giving.
然后，就在那儿，离 Pico 和 Bundy 附近的公路高架桥不远，他进入了我的角色，开始讲我应该讲的推销语。
Hey, look, can I get two minutes from you? So here's the thing. You probably know me, producer of This American Life, been doing it for 15 years. You know it's the most successful radio show, top of the podcasts in iTunes, et cetera.
嘿，听着，能给我两分钟吗？事情是这样的。你可能知道我，我是《美国生活》的制作人，干了 15 年了。你知道这是最成功的广播节目，iTunes 播客排名前列，等等。
So here's the thing. I realize there's a hunger for this kind of content out there and there's none of this [BLEEP]. It's just a bunch of jerk [BLEEP] podcasts. Nothing's out there.
所以事情是这样的。我意识到外面有对这种内容的渴望，但这里根本没有这种[哔]的内容。到处都是一堆混蛋[哔]播客。根本没东西。
Advertisers are dying for it. Users are dying for it. And if you look at the macro environment, we're seeing more and more podcast integrations into cars. People want this content. It's a whole new button in the latest version of iOS.
广告商在渴求它，用户在渴求它。如果你看看宏观环境，我们看到越来越多的播客整合进汽车。人们想要这个内容。在最新版 iOS 里有个全新的按钮。
So here's the thing. Nobody else can make this [BLEEP]. I know how to make it better than anybody else in the world. And so I've already identified a few key areas where I know there's hunger for the podcast. We've got the subject matter. We're going to launch this [BLEEP]. I know there's advertisers who want to get involved with it.
所以事情是这样的。没别人能做出这种[哔]内容。我知道我能比世界上任何人都做得更好。所以我已经确定了几个人们渴求播客的关键领域。我们有题材。我们要推出这个[哔]东西。我知道有广告商想参与进来。
But here's the unfair advantage I have. Because of what I've done in my past careers with This American Life and with Planet Money , people are actually willing to just straight-up pay for this stuff. And I'm not just talking about traditional subscriptions. I'm talking-- we did this T-shirt experiment at Planet Money where we got $600,000 coming in, where people actually gave us money to buy a t-shirt with our logo on it as part of the content. It was integrated directly. And I know we can replicate that across these other platforms.
但这是我不公平的竞争优势。因为我过去在《美国生活》和《Planet Money》的职业生涯所做的事情，人们实际上愿意直接为这些内容付费。我指的不仅仅是传统的订阅。我在说——我们在《Planet Money》做过一次 T 恤实验，我们获得了 60 万美元的收入，人们实际上付钱买了一件印有我们标志的 T 恤，作为内容的一部分。它被直接整合进去了。而且我知道我们可以在这些其他平台上复制这一点。
So here's what we're doing. We're putting together a million and a half dollars. That's going to buy us three, four guys who are going to launch these three podcasts in the next 12 months. We think very easily we could get to 300,000, 400,000 net subscribers across the whole thing.
所以这就是我们要做的。我们正在筹集 150 万美元。那将雇佣三、四个家伙，在接下来的 12 个月内推出这三个播客。我们认为很容易就能在整个体系中获得 30 万到 40 万的净订阅用户。
With CPMs where they are in this market right now, I know on advertising alone, we could get to break even. But as we do more of this integration, we get people texting in to donate to this stuff, buying some of this product, doing some of these integrated episodes, I know that we're going to have on our hands here something that will ultimately scale to be a network of 12, 15 podcasts. The audience is there. They want it. Nobody else can do it like we can. Are you in?
以当前市场的 CPM（每千次展示成本），我知道单凭广告，我们就能实现盈亏平衡。但随着我们做更多的整合，我们让人们发短信捐赠，购买一些产品，做一些整合剧集，我知道我们将掌握一些东西，最终会扩展为一个拥有 12 到 15 个播客的网络。受众在那里。他们想要它。没人能像我们这样做到。你加入吗？
That was amazing!
那太令人惊叹了！
That's your story, right?
那是你的故事，对吧？
That is great. Holy [BLEEP]. I thought I was a storyteller. Now I feel bad about my job.
太棒了。天哪[哔]。我以为自己是个讲故事的人。现在我对自己这份工作感到羞愧了。
So what--
所以什么——
That was good.
那太好了。
So good that I'm thinking, oh, if he pitched my idea that well, he must be into it, right? He's going to invest. But then he goes on.
太好了，以至于我在想，噢，如果他把我的想法讲得这么好，他肯定感兴趣，对吧？他会投资的。但随后他继续说道。
I could come at it from the other side. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Media's very, very hard, as you know. This content's really hard to consume. It's longer form. You're counting on people spending that kind of dedicated time. I mean, you're fighting an overall trend of attention, and every other format is going to shorter and shorter content pieces. And so you're actually swimming upstream with that stuff.
我可以从另一方面来说。是的，是的，是的。媒体非常非常难，如你所知。这种内容很难消费。这是长篇幅的。你指望人们花费那种专门的时间。我的意思是，你在与注意力的总体趋势作斗争，其他所有格式都在往越来越短的内容发展。所以你实际上是在逆水行舟。
You have a lot of platform risk, because you're depending upon Apple and Google to distribute your content. The kind of stuff you're doing with Planet Money is exciting, but it's all under the veil of being a nonprofit. People feel a moral obligation to contribute to those kinds of things. You come outside from under the public radio veil, and you have to worry about whether people are going to be a little bit jaded and feel like they don't necessarily need to donate to a for-profit company to make for-profit content for guys who are doing this for equity and hoping to get rich.
你有很大的平台风险，因为你依赖苹果和谷歌来分发内容。你在《Planet Money》做的事情很令人兴奋，但那都是在非营利组织的遮羞布下进行的。人们觉得有道德义务为这类事情做贡献。你走出公共广播的遮羞布，你就得担心人们是否会有点愤世嫉俗，觉得他们不必一定要捐钱给一家营利性公司，去制作营利性内容，给那些寻求股权并希望发财的人。
You know, frankly, you think you might actually be uniquely qualified to do this, but we've started to see more and more news podcasts make their way out there. Some stuff from Khan Academy is moving up the ladder right now. So ultimately, you're not going to be the only guys in here, and it's going to be pretty competitive. Audio is kind of a niche market, and so I don't know. I don't-- I don't know if this is a fit for us.
你知道，坦白说，你觉得你可能确实有独特的资格做这件事，但我们已经开始看到越来越多的新闻播客涌现出来。可汗学院（Khan Academy）的一些内容现在正在向上爬。所以归根结底，你不会是唯一的玩家，竞争会相当激烈。音频算是一个小众市场，所以我不知道。我不知道——我不知道这是否适合我们。
At this point, I have no idea what to think. I'm drained, my pits are drenched, and Chris Sacca has just given me two completely convincing cases in favor of and against investing in my business. Whatever shred of conviction I had about this process at the beginning is gone.
在这一点上，我不知道该想什么。我筋疲力尽，腋下湿透，克里斯·萨卡刚刚给了我两个关于是否投资我的生意、完全令人信服的案例。我在开始时对这个过程所持有的那点信念已经荡然无存。
I also learned something about how investors like Chris see the companies they might invest in. I came out here thinking I could build a nice profitable business, but Chris isn't looking for profitable. He's looking for Twitter, something huge. Or if not Twitter, then at least a company he could sell to Twitter or some other big company.
我也学到了一些关于克里斯这样的投资者如何看待他们可能投资的公司的东西。我来到这里以为自己能建立一家不错的营利性公司，但克里斯并不在寻找“营利”。他在寻找下一个 Twitter，那种巨大的东西。或者如果不是 Twitter，至少是一家他可以卖给 Twitter 或其他大公司从而退出的小公司。
He asked me this question. What would the exit be? And by that he means, what large company will buy your company in three to five years so investors like me can get our money back at 10 to 100 times the amount we put in?
他问了我这个问题。退出的方式是什么？他的意思是，哪家大公司会在三到五年内买下你的公司，好让我们这些投资者能以投入金额 10 到 100 倍的回报拿回我们的钱？
I hadn't really thought about that question. I don't know if I want anyone to buy me. This experience with Chris makes me realize this simple vision I have, it's not a vision people like him are looking to invest in.
我真的没考虑过那个问题。我不知道我是否想让任何人买下我。这次与克里斯的经历让我意识到，我拥有的这个简单愿景，并不是他这类人想要投资的愿景。
This was my big chance, a huge Silicon Valley investor with enough money to snap his fingers and get me started on my new life, and I'd blown it. My failure, it seemed clear, had nothing to do with my shoes.
这是我的绝佳机会，一位硅谷大投资者，有足够的钱只要打个响指就能让我开始新生活，而我却把它搞砸了。我的失败，似乎很明显，与我的鞋子毫无关系。
Alex Blumberg is not quite a businessman in New York City. As he continues trying to start his business, he's going to be documenting each painful step-- and the occasional success, too, we hope-- on a new podcast. The podcast is called "StartUp." One quick sample. In the episode where Alex tries to come up with a name for his company, he gets his wife, Nazanin, to weigh in on one of the leading contenders.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格还不是纽约市的一名企业家。随着他继续尝试创办他的生意，他将记录下每一个痛苦的步骤——我们希望也偶尔有成功——在一个新的播客上。这个播客叫《StartUp》。快速预览一下。在亚历克斯试图为公司取名的那一集里，他让他的妻子纳扎宁对其中一个候选名单进行了评价。
Orelo.
Orelo。
Orelo? What is that? What is that supposed to mean?
Orelo？那是什么？那是什么意思？
Well, it's, uh-- it's "ear" in Esperanto.
嗯，它是——它是世界语中的“耳朵”（ear）。
[BURSTS OUT LAUGHING]
（爆笑）
Oh, my god!
噢，天哪！
[CONTINUES LAUGHING]
（继续大笑）
That's so dumb. That's so dumb.
那太蠢了。那太蠢了。
The "StartUp" podcast is that hearstartup.com. That's hear, H-E-A-R, startup.com. Coming up, Mike Birbiglia and why anyone starting a business lives low to the ground. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
《StartUp》播客网址是 hearstartup.com。那是 hear，H-E-A-R，startup.com。接下来，迈克·比尔比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）以及为什么任何创业的人都要活得脚踏实地。稍后继续收听，来自芝加哥公共广播的节目。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "It's the Person, Not the Product." We have stories of businesses in their very early stages and the people trying to start them, and what happens when you know the most important thing you need to do is to win over people, make friends, influence people, and you also know you are not doing it. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "The Business of Show."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目主题是“是人，而不是产品”。我们有关于创业初期以及那些试图开创它们的人的故事，还有当你明知你需要做的最重要的事情是赢取人心、结交朋友、影响他人，而你又明知自己没做到时会发生什么。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“表演的生意”。
Being a comedian, I have to say, is-- it's a little bit like starting a business where no one wants that business to exist. Really. Like, no one. Not your family, or your friends, or the audience. And in so many ways, they're right.
我必须说，成为一名喜剧演员有点像开一家没人希望它存在的公司。真的。就像，没人希望。你的家人、朋友，还是观众。而在很多方面，他们是对的。
They're right, of course, because you are bad. That is comedian Mike Birbiglia. And he says at first you just do not know what you're doing. And he says that the normal laws of supply and demand, they apply to the comedy business. And so at first, there is no demand for you and your services. He tells this story from his early days trying to start the business of his own comedy career out of nothing, with nobody believing in him.
当然，他们是对的，因为你很烂。那位是喜剧演员迈克·比尔比利亚。他说起初你根本不知道自己在做什么。他说供需的基本法则同样适用于喜剧行业。所以起初，人们对你和你的服务没有需求。他讲述了他早期尝试从零开始建立自己的喜剧事业的故事，当时没人相信他。
When I moved to New York 13 years ago to become a comedian, my parents were very upset, because my-- and they really, really were. They were very concerned. My dad is a doctor, my mom is a nurse-- those are professions where people help other people and are ashamed of their artistic children.
当我 13 年前搬到纽约成为一名喜剧演员时，我的父母非常沮丧，因为我的——他们真的、真的非常担心。我爸爸是医生，我妈妈是护士——那些职业里的人都在帮助他人，并为他们那艺术家的孩子感到羞耻。
But my parents were so worried when I moved to New York. And in fairness, I mean, I was really struggling. I was broke. I was living on an air mattress in Queens. I couldn't afford a dresser for my clothes.
但我搬到纽约时，父母非常担心。说实话，我当时确实在挣扎。我破产了，住在皇后区的一张充气床垫上。我买不起放衣服的梳妆台。
When you're broke, everything is low to the ground, you know? Like, you roll off your air mattress in the morning. You grab some pants from the floor. You cook noodles on a hot plate. One falls out of your mouth, you're like, "Aw, it's not too far!" You know?
当你身无分文时，一切都贴近地面，你知道吗？就像，你早上从充气床垫上滚下来，从地板上抓起裤子，在电炉上煮面条。有一根面条从嘴里掉出来，你会觉得，“噢，没掉多远！”你知道吗？
And I couldn't even get past at the clubs in New York City, which is the real only reason I moved there. So I drove my mom's station wagon around the country to areas of lesser comedy concentration, places like Ohio and West Virginia and New Jersey. And I bought my mom's car. That's an important detail. Because I found out recently that sometimes when people's parents have faith in their child's dreams, they'll just give them their car.
而且我甚至无法在纽约的俱乐部演出，那是我搬到那里的唯一真正原因。所以我开着我妈妈的旅行车在全国各地跑，去那些喜剧浓度较低的地区，像俄亥俄州、西弗吉尼亚州和新泽西州。我买了我妈妈的车。这是一个重要的细节。因为我最近发现，有时候当父母对孩子的梦想有信心时，他们会直接把车送给他们。
My mom upcharged me on the station wagon. She got the full Blue Book value for the vehicle. She was like, this guy just doesn't have it. I gotta get the short money out now.
我妈妈在旅行车上加了价。她拿到了那辆车的全额二手车估价。她当时想，这家伙没戏，我现在得把能赚的快钱赚到手。
I remember this particularly low point for me when I was performing in a comedy club in New Jersey, and I was driving back down the ramp into the Lincoln Tunnel, and towards my air mattress in Queens. And the cop just sort of waved me over. You realize, when you're broke, that cops will just pull you over if you have a crappy car to see what else you've got going wrong in your life. They'll just be like, "You! Come here. We're going to figure out what you've done."
我记得这对我来说是一个特别低谷的时刻，当时我在新泽西的一家喜剧俱乐部表演，我沿着斜坡开回林肯隧道，朝我皇后区的充气床垫开去。警察示意我靠边停车。你意识到，当你破产时，如果你的车很烂，警察会直接拦下你，看看你生活中还有什么别的问题。他们会说，“你！过来。我们要弄清楚你到底做了什么。”
And the cop says, "License and registration." As I'm pulling out my license, I'm realizing that it is expired by three weeks. So he was right.
警察说：“驾照和行车证。”当我拿出驾照时，我意识到它已经过期三周了。所以他是对的。
And I had that moment where I'm thinking, wait, should I preface this conversation with this key piece of information? Like, "All right, you're not gonna like this!" You know, like, "Same team! We both think I'm an idiot!"
那一刻我在想，等等，我应该先说出这个关键信息吗？比如，“好吧，你不会喜欢这个的！”你知道，就像，“同一队！我们都觉得我是个白痴！”
I didn't mention it. He goes back to the cruiser. He's there for 15 minutes, because there's a lot to do. And then when he comes back, he's a little more stern. He says, "Did you know that your license is suspended?"
我没提这事。他回到警车里。他在那里待了 15 分钟，因为有很多工作要做。当他回来时，他变得严厉了一些。他说：“你知道你的驾照被吊销了吗？”
Yeah. See, I didn't-- I didn't know what suspended meant. I was very naive. Apparently I had an unpaid speeding ticket from high school, and my family moved. They don't forward registry mail, and so I said to him, and I quote, I said, "Yes. No. Wait, what does suspended mean?"
是的。看，我没——我不知道“吊销”是什么意思。我当时很天真。显然我高中时有一张未缴纳的超速罚单，而我家里搬家了。他们不转寄挂号信，所以我对他说，引用原话，我说：“是。不。等等，吊销是什么意思？”
And he said, "Please step out of the car." And I said, "No, no, no, I'm serious. I don't know what suspended means," thinking we were having away a witty repartee.
他说：“请下车。”我说：“不，不，不，我是认真的，我不知道吊销是什么意思，”以为我们在进行一场诙谐的对谈。
And he says, "Please step out of the car." And so I step out of the car. And he says, "You're under arrest." And I said, "I don't think so." And he says, "Yes, I'm sure of it." And then he cuffs me up against the car and put me in the back of the cruiser.
他又说：“请下车。”于是我下了车。他说：“你被捕了。”我说：“我不觉得。”他说：“是的，我确定。”然后他把我铐在车上，把我关进警车后座。
Here's what I didn't know about when you get arrested. This is a revelation. They don't have to take you to jail right away. So I'm in cuffs, watching through the windshield, as this guy is just hanging out with his cop buddies, having a great time, laughing, like, "Hahaha! The Mets!" or whatever. "Ah, I arrested this guy for nuttin'!" You know?
这是我被捕时不知道的一件事。这是一个启发。他们不必立刻把你带去监狱。所以我戴着手铐，透过挡风玻璃看着，那个家伙只是和他的警察哥们闲逛，玩得很开心，大笑，就像，“哈哈哈！大都会队！”什么的。“啊，我没理由地逮捕了这个家伙！”你知道吗？
And so I'm afraid. And then I'm sweaty. And then I'm itchy. I had an itch on my face. And I didn't have any extremities available to scratch the itch. And so I'm looking around, like the character from No Country for Old Men, and I see a door handle. And I'm like, OK, I can work with this. And I reach my face over. And I'm scratching it against the door handle.
我感到害怕。然后我开始流汗。然后我开始发痒。我的脸上有个痒点，但我没有多余的肢体可以去挠那个痒。所以我四处张望，就像《老无所依》里的角色，我看到了一个门把手。我想，好的，这招能行。于是我把脸凑过去，对着门把手挠。
But that just creates more itches-- on my face, on my shoulder, on my chin. And then I'm sort of writhing around in circles in the back of the cruiser like a dog trying to shake his medical cone. And the cop looks back. He's like, "We got a live one!"
但这只会造成更多的痒——在脸上，肩膀上，下巴上。然后我在警车后座像一只试图摆脱脖子上伊丽莎白圈的狗一样扭来扭去。警察往后看。他说：“我们抓到一个活宝！”
"What the hell are you doing?" I'm like-- (DESPERATELY)  "Will you scratch my face?" Apparently they never do that. It turns out no one's even asked before, which is crazy to me.
“你到底在干什么？”我说——（绝望地）“你能帮我挠挠脸吗？”显然他们从不那样做。结果发现之前甚至没人问过，这让我觉得很疯狂。
The officer booked me at the Weehawken, New Jersey jail. And he even took the shoelaces out of my shoes, because apparently it's a very common thing when people's licenses are suspended because they hang themselves. And I don't like to joke about it. It's called suspension post-suspension. All too common. Under-reported.
警官在新泽西州威霍肯（Weehawken）监狱给我办了入册手续。他甚至取下了我鞋子上的鞋带，因为显然这是当人们驾照被吊销时非常常见的事情，因为他们会自杀。我不喜欢拿这个开玩笑。这叫吊销后的吊销。非常普遍。未被充分报道。
And and then he took a mug shot of me. And he knew I was-- he knew I'd performed at a comedy club that night, and so he took an extra one, and he put it in his pocket. And he goes, "This is in case you ever get famous."
然后他给我拍了一张入册照片。他知道我——他知道我那天晚上在喜剧俱乐部表演，所以他多拍了一张，放进了口袋里。他说：“这是以防你将来出名。”
Which I thought was nice. 'Cause at least he's rooting for me. I mean, sure, he's arresting me now, but long-term, this guy sees it. Which is more than I can say for my mom. Thank you.
我觉得这很好。因为至少他在为我加油。我的意思是，当然，他现在逮捕了我，但长远来看，这家伙看好我。这比我妈给我的支持多多了。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Mike Birbiglia. His 100-city comedy tour includes The Chicago Theatre and two cities in New Jersey. Details at birbigs.com.
迈克·比尔比利亚。他的 100 城市喜剧巡演包括芝加哥剧院和新泽西州的两个城市。详情请见 birbigs.com。
[MUSIC - "DRIVING ON 9" BY THE BREEDERS]
（音乐——The Breeders 的《Driving on 9》）
Act Three, "The Other Real World." You know, when you start a business, it usually takes over your life, at least for a while. This last story is about somebody throwing herself into a business plan that is really actually an entire life plan to last a lifetime. The story was produced for a podcast called Love +  Radio . And this story is unusual in so many ways and is just great. The woman who's speaking in the story is named Taylor Rose Nations. Here's Taylor.
第三幕，“另一个现实世界”。你知道，当你创业时，它通常会占据你的生活，至少有一段时间。最后一个故事关于某个人全身心投入到一个商业计划中，而那实际上是一个持续终生的完整人生计划。这个故事是为名为《Love + Radio》的播客制作的。这个故事在很多方面都很不寻常，而且非常棒。故事中说话的女士名叫泰勒·罗斯·内申斯（Taylor Rose Nations）。这是泰勒。
When I was a nursing assistant, I took care of a lady who couldn't chew any food. Bad teeth, she didn't want to go get them pulled out-- she was so old. She just, like, was cool with drinking juice the rest of her life. And her family decided that it would be better for her to get her teeth pulled and get dentures. She ended up getting her teeth pulled. And after that, she refused to eat. And she ended up just dying.
当我是护士助理时，我照顾过一位不能咀嚼任何食物的女士。牙齿很烂，她不想去拔掉——她太老了。她只是觉得余生喝果汁过日子也挺好。她的家人认为拔掉牙齿并装上假牙对她更好。最终她拔了牙。在那之后，她拒绝进食。结果她就那样死去了。
After somebody dies, we strip the bed, sanitize the room. It's this whole thing. And the next patient called me in and she asked me, "Did somebody just die in this bed?" And I said, "Uh, yeah. [LAUGHS] They did." And she said, "I thought so, because they just bit me."
有人去世后，我们清理床铺，消毒房间。整套程序都是这样。下一位病人把我叫进去，问我：“这张床上刚才是不是有人去世了？”我说：“呃，是的。（笑）是的。”她说：“我想也是，因为他们刚才咬了我一口。”
And I was just like, what are you talking about? And she said, "Yeah, they just bit me, and I reached back to where they bit me and I found this." And it was a tooth, like a full tooth with, like, the roots and-- And I said, "Are you sure that's not your tooth?" And she was like, "I'm pretty sure I'd know if I lost a tooth."
我当时就想，你在说什么？她说：“是的，他们刚才咬了我，我摸了摸被咬的地方，发现了这个。”那是一颗牙齿，就像一颗完整的牙齿，带有牙根——我问她：“你确定那不是你自己的牙吗？”她说：“如果我掉了一颗牙我肯定会知道。”
If I hadn't had those experiences, I would probably 100% say, like, you just die. You stop living. But who knows? I haven't died yet. I don't believe in, like, an afterlife in a biblical sense or anything like that. I kind of think you probably just stop being.
如果我没有那些经历，我可能会 100% 说，人死了就只是死了。你停止了生活。但谁知道呢？我还没死过。我不相信圣经意义上的那种“来世”之类的东西。我有点认为你可能只是停止了存在。
I think there are probably a lot of things that I'll miss. My family, and books. Pizza, and beer, especially. If nobody's actually looked at the website, I think it kind of sounds crazy. I think most people think I'm, like, getting sucked into some weird cult.
我想可能有很多我会错过的事情。我的家人，书。披萨和啤酒，尤其是。如果没人看过那个网站，我觉得这听起来很疯狂。我想大多数人都觉得我像被卷入了某个奇怪的邪教。
I literally never go to the doctor, so I was nervous anyway. Having to make that appointment kind of made this a little bit more real an experience. Vision test, colorblind, hearing, breathing, blood work, blood pressure. Then I had to have an EKG done. Pelvic exam.
我几乎从不去医生那里，所以我本来就很紧张。必须预约体检让这件事变得更真实了一些。视力测试、色盲测试、听力、呼吸、验血、血压。然后我不得不做了心电图，还有盆腔检查。
You had to get like a gynecologist, too?
你也得去看妇科医生？
Yeah.
是的。
Really?
真的？
Like the whole thing.
整个一套流程。
What is the-- do you know what the purpose of that was?
目的是什么——你知道那是什么目的吗？
I think the whole thing is just to make sure that you're completely disease-free. Like you don't have cervical cancer or, you know, AIDS.
我想这一切只是为了确保你完全没有任何疾病。比如你没有宫颈癌或者，你知道，艾滋病。
I work as a chemist. That's my-- basically my first job out of college, and I don't want to work there forever. My mixing station and where I do a lot of research and development is on the same bench as my computer, so I just stream The Bachelor and work on formulas. [LAUGHS] And then quickly pause it if anybody came in. Minimize!
我是一名化学家。这是我——基本上是我大学毕业后的第一份工作，我不想永远在那里工作。我的混合工作台和我进行大量研发的地方与我的电脑在同一个长椅上，所以我只是边放《单身汉》（The Bachelor）边研究公式。（笑）如果有人进来就赶紧暂停它。最小化！
Then don't tell me you love [BLEEP] me. Don't tell me that. That, to me, is not a man.
那就别告诉我你爱[哔]我。别告诉我那个。对我来说，那不是个男人。
The Bachelor is a very silly show where a bunch of ladies try to date the same guy. The Bachelor might offer you the key to the fantasy suite. You can take it or you can pass.
《单身汉》是一个非常愚蠢的节目，一群女士试图和同一个男人约会。《单身汉》可能会给你提供幻想套房的钥匙。你可以接受，也可以拒绝。
That I want to propose to you.
我想要向你求婚。
Juan Pablo, who is The Bachelor now, the season I applied for--
胡安·巴勃罗（Juan Pablo），也就是现在的那位“单身汉”，我申请的那一季——
I'm 100% sure.
我 100% 确定。
Super cute.
超级可爱。
That I-- I just-- I want to let you go.
我——我只是——我想让你走。
I am in. I'm single. Uh, I got nothing going on. I'll be on The Bachelor . You get to go fly around the world and go on all these crazy dates, go to the fantasy suite if you want to. [LAUGHS] Totally in.
我加入了。我是单身。呃，我没事干。我会去上《单身汉》。你可以飞往世界各地，去参加所有那些疯狂的约会，如果你想的话，还能去幻想套房。（笑）绝对加入。
I like you a lot. A lot. So, um--
我很喜欢你。非常喜欢。所以，嗯——
So I kept joking that if my Bachelor application fell through, at least I'd have this to fall back on. Which was kind of funny, because my Bachelor application did fall through, and-- and here I am.
所以我一直开玩笑说，如果我的《单身汉》申请没通过，至少我还有这个退路。这很有趣，因为我的《单身汉》申请确实没通过——而我却在这里。
They had said by the end of December 2013, we'll hear something. That week comes, I realize I hadn't heard anything. I want to hear something soon. And I woke up, and I always check my email in the morning on my phone. And I got that letter, and like, did the whole eye-rubbing, like, "No way!" thing.
他们说在 2013 年 12 月底之前，我们会有消息。那周到了，我意识到我还没听到任何消息。我想要尽快听到消息。我醒来，总会在手机上查看早晨的电子邮件。我收到了那封信，做了一套“揉眼睛”动作，心想：“不可能吧！”
"Dear Miss Taylor Rose Nations, you and only 1,057 others around the globe have been preselected as potential candidates to launch the dawn of a new era, human life on Mars. Congratulations, you have made it to the next round. Now catch your breath."
“亲爱的泰勒·罗斯·内申斯女士，你和全球仅有的 1057 名其他人一起，已被预选为潜在候选人，以开启一个新时代——火星上的人类生活。恭喜，你已经进入了下一轮。现在，先喘口气吧。”
Mars One will establish human settlement on Mars in 2023. In that year, the first group of four humans will land on Mars.
“火星一号”（Mars One）将于 2023 年在火星建立人类定居点。那一年，第一批四个人类将登陆火星。
The Dutch organization Mars One hopes to build a community of settlers on the planet.
荷兰组织“火星一号”希望在火星上建立一个定居者社区。
Every two years after that, another group will join the settlement.
此后每两年，另一组人将加入定居点。
It's an idea belonging to Bas Lansdorp.
这是一个属于巴斯·兰斯多普（Bas Lansdorp）的想法。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
I am Bas Lansdorp, and I am organizing a human mission to the planet Mars in the year 2023.
我是巴斯·兰斯多普，我正在组织一次 2023 年的人类火星任务。
Mars One has designed a mission that is much simpler than previous designs for Mars missions. The most significant simplification is that the crew is actually going to stay and live on Mars with the intention to remain there for the rest of their lives.
“火星一号”设计的任务比以往的火星任务设计简单得多。最显著的简化在于，船员实际上将留在火星上生活，并打算在那里度过余生。
Jumped out of bed. My roommate was down the hall, and I was knocking on her door, freaking out. I'm like Megan! I'm going to Mars! She said, "That's [BLEEP] awesome!"
我从床上跳了起来。我的室友在走廊尽头，我在敲她的门，快疯了。我说：梅根！我要去火星了！她说：“那太[哔]酷了！”
I'm, like, just sitting in the living room, thinking, like, this could actually happen. I'm just rereading that letter over and over and realizing that I didn't feel-- I didn't feel scared about it. I wasn't worried.
我只是坐在客厅里，心想，这真的可能发生。我一遍又一遍地重读那封信，意识到我并不感到——我并不为此害怕。我不担心。
When I told my dad, I was in Whistler, and he had been watching Game of Thrones , which I got him for Christmas. I told him I had been accepted and that there were 1,000 of us left. It was silent on the phone for like 30 seconds. He got all teary, and said, "Aw, you're going to Mars, and Ned Stark's getting his head chopped off. What's next?"
我告诉我爸爸时，我在惠斯勒，他当时在看我圣诞节送他的《权力的游戏》。我告诉他我被录取了，还剩下 1000 人。电话那头沉默了大约 30 秒。他声音哽咽，说：“噢，你要去火星了，而奈德·史塔克（Ned Stark）要被砍头了。接下来是什么？”
The one-way mission means we don't ever get to come home. But we're going to be setting up camp there. A lot of people have been talking to me, like, is this a scam? You had to pay $35 to apply. Do they just want your money?
单程任务意味着我们永远无法回家。但我们要在那里安营扎寨。很多人跟我聊天，说这是不是骗局？你申请时得付 35 美元。他们是不是只想要你的钱？
"Don't go! You're just a human guinea pig." I don't mind. If I can go to Mars and be a human guinea pig, I'm willing to sort of donate my body to science.
“别去！你只是个活体实验品。”我不介意。如果我能去火星并当一个活体实验品，我愿意把我的身体捐给科学。
I feel like it's worth it for me, personally, and it's kind of a selfish thing, but just to turn around and look and see Earth, like that's a lifelong, like, total dream. Never thought in a million years that that would be something I could ever experience. That, to me, is worth the whole thing, worth, like, my spaceship crashing or getting taken advantage of. To me, that in itself is worth it.
我觉得这对我也许值得，这有点自私，但仅仅是转过身看看地球，那就是一个终生的梦想。一百万年我也没想过那是我能经历的事情。对我来说，这本身就值得，哪怕我的飞船坠毁或被利用。对我来说，仅仅这一点就值得了。
Oh, you know what? They did have a handicapped girl. They had a chick-- whoa! They have a pregnant one?
噢，你知道吗？他们确实有个残疾女孩。他们有个妹子——哇！他们还有一个怀孕的？
And so this is the season that you applied for, right?
这就是你申请的那一季，对吧？
Yeah. I sent out my application for The Bachelor and Mars One around the same time.
是的。我大约在同一时间提交了《单身汉》和“火星一号”的申请。
I take a step back and I see them, and I'm like, wow, you're lucky, man.
我退后一步看着他们，心想，哇，你真幸运，伙计。
All the girls, they have, like, 30 seconds to sell themselves to this dude when they walk out of the limo. Some of them tumble out and do gymnastics, and others have prepared jokes.
所有的女孩，她们从加长豪华轿车里走出来时，只有 30 秒向那个男人推销自己。有些人踉踉跄跄出来表演体操，另一些人准备了笑话。
Hi, I'm Chris Harrison.
嗨，我是克里斯·哈里森（Chris Harrison）。
Oh. Here he is. Love that guy.
噢。他在这里。爱死这个家伙了。
Welcome to the new season of The Bachelor .
欢迎来到新一季的《单身汉》。
And how do you think that's going to be, going from a view of reality TV to being the person that could potentially be in a lifelong reality TV show?
你觉得从一个真人秀的视角转变为可能生活在一个终身真人秀里的人，那会是什么感觉？
Unlike The Bachelor , where you're on a show and it's a season, and you go and you vacation and make out with Juan Pablo, like, if you actually get selected for Mars One, it's the rest of your life. So it's probably really important to be completely authentic. That way you're not selected on false pretenses, and-- and then you end up hating everything. [LAUGHS] And, yeah.
不像《单身汉》，你在节目里只有一季，你去度假，和胡安·巴勃罗亲热，如果你真的被选上“火星一号”，那是你的余生。所以彻底真实可能非常重要。这样你就不会因为虚假借口而被选中——然后结果你讨厌这一切。（笑）是的。
And you're going to be there with only three other people, right?
而且你只能和另外三个人待在那里，对吧？
Mhm. That's the plan.
嗯哼。这是计划。
Do you ever think to yourself, like, that's not a lot of options for potential sexual partners?
你有没有想过，那个潜在性伴侣的选择不多？
[LAUGHS] Mm, yes. But I also think at least initially, we will basically just be trying to survive. And so we probably won't be-- well, I don't know. I don't know. Yeah, I've thought about that a little bit. But also, four more people are coming in two years, so that's like seven people. [LAUGHS] Water, food, a good book, and a vibrator-- you're set. [LAUGHS]
（笑）嗯，有。但我同时也觉得至少最初，我们基本上只是在试图生存。所以我们可能不会——嗯，我不知道。我不知道。是的，我想过一点。但再过两年会有四个人过来，那就是七个人了。（笑）水、食物、一本好书和一个振动器——你就全齐了。（笑）
So I had submitted my application to Mars One probably a few months prior to submitting my video. You don't have to do it all at once. So we developed a little script about me in the future, when Earth's gone to [BLEEP]. And it's really dorky and it's awful. And hope nobody's ever seen it or will ever watch it.
所以我提交“火星一号”申请可能比提交视频早几个月。你不必一次性做完。所以我们编了一个关于我在未来的小剧本，那时地球已经变成[哔]了。它真的很呆，很糟糕。希望没人见过，或以后会看它。
My name is Taylor. The date is March 10, 2085. And I'm here in America. Things on Earth are getting worse every day.
我的名字是泰勒。日期是 2085 年 3 月 10 日。我在这里，在美国。地球上的情况每天都在恶化。
With the rising sea levels, we're all forced to live so close to each other, and disease is spreading rampantly. We've got no food. We've got no drinking water left. What is available as being hoarded by those with money. People are dying in the streets of dehydration and starvation.
随着海平面上升，我们都被迫生活得非常拥挤，疾病正在迅速蔓延。我们没有食物了。没有剩下的饮用水了。现有的资源正被有钱人囤积。人们死在街头上，死于脱水和饥饿。
The hurricanes are coming almost constantly now, and there's no escaping them. I fear that the end is near. Why did we not do something about this while we had the chance? Why did we not expand beyond Earth? Why did we not go to Mars?
飓风现在几乎不断地袭来，无处可逃。我担心末日临近了。为什么我们在有机会的时候没有为此做些什么？为什么我们没有扩展到地球之外？为什么我们没有去火星？
Status Buster?
状态克星（Status Buster）？
Go.
继续。
Chancey?
钱西（Chancey）？
Go.
继续。
Go ahead and throttle up, CAPCOM. Fido?
继续，CAPCOM（航天飞机通信官）。Fido（飞行控制官）？
Go.
继续。
Buster?
克星？
Go.
继续。
[VOICES CONTINUE  AND FADE]
（声音持续并淡出）
It's funny how much added value everyday experiences kind of have when you know that you-- in 10 years, you might not have any of those anymore. I guess it's kind of like if you know when you're going to die. Like, your know when your day on Earth is. All of your days up to that day will be so much more important, and you'll experience them so much more than if you were just going on like everybody else. Especially at night, when it's windy and dry, I'm just like, I only have a set amount of these left.
有趣的是，当你明知——10 年后你可能不再拥有那些东西时，日常经历会拥有多少附加值。我想这有点像如果你知道自己什么时候会死。比如，你知道你在地球上的日子还剩多少。在那之前的所有日子都会变得重要得多，你会比那些像往常一样生活的人更深刻地体验它们。特别是在晚上，当风很大而且干燥时，我只是想，我只剩下这么多了。
This is extraordinary project. No taxpayers' money will be involved.
这是一个非凡的项目。不会动用任何纳税人的钱。
We will finance this mission by creating the biggest media event ever around.
我们将通过创造有史以来最大的媒体事件来资助这次任务。
It's a Big Brother -style competition.
这是一个像《老大哥》（Big Brother）风格的竞赛。
This is going to be a media spectacle. Big Brother will pale in comparison.
这将是一场媒体奇观。《老大哥》与之相比都显得黯然失色。
So everybody can watch as we progress, the astronauts are selected, as they go into training, and as they explore Mars.
所以每个人都可以看着我们的进展，宇航员被选中，他们进入训练，以及他们探索火星。
The whole world will be watching and experience this journey.
全世界都将观看并体验这段旅程。
I kind of feel like 1,058 people just volunteered for a tribute, like The Hunger Games . And we're all just kind of like standing around, wondering what's going to happen.
我感觉就像 1058 个人刚刚自愿成为了贡品，就像《饥饿游戏》。我们都只是站在那里，想知道会发生什么。
When I picture the launch, I picture a lot of media. From that point forward, our entire lives will be televised.
当我想象发射时，我想到很多媒体。从那时起，我们的整个余生都将被电视转播。
I think the lead-up to takeoff is going to be harder than post-takeoff, because it's, like, all this attention, and-- and you have to kind of be a public figure. Nobody knows who I am right now, but 10 years from now, people will, if things go as planned.
我觉得发射前的阶段会比发射后更难，因为有那么多的关注——而且你必须成为一个公众人物。现在没人知道我是谁，但如果计划按部就班，10 年后人们就会知道了。
But it seems like you're-- like that would definitely be attention on you.
但这看起来你——那肯定会把关注点放在你身上。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
You know, how do you think you're going to handle that as someone who's sort of nervous?
你知道，你觉得作为一个有点紧张的人，你会怎么处理那个？
I think it's getting easier. I feel like every year, I sort of feel a little bit more comfortable in my own skin, if that makes sense. I still do the whole awkward robot thing, but now I just embrace it. [LAUGHS]
我觉得正在变得容易。我觉得每年，我都能让自己感觉在自己的皮肤里更自在一点，如果这说得通的话。我还是会做那种尴尬的机器人动作，但现在我只是拥抱它。（笑）
So it's gotten less-- it's still hard. But I feel like I've been purposely putting myself out there a lot more than I have. I'm trying to put myself in social situations where I don't know people, and like, I have to learn to talk to people. Or, like, I've been going on dates a little bit.
所以它变少——这依然很难。但我感觉我一直在刻意地让自己比以前多得多地展露出来。我试着让自己处于不知道人们的社交场合，比如，我得学习跟人交谈。或者，比如，我最近开始稍微约会了。
But I'm not at all in a rush to commit to anything. Not looking for long-term relationships. I've got 10 years, people.
但我一点也不急于承诺任何事情。不寻求长期关系。我有 10 年时间，伙计们。
You know, I think about it a lot, that I only have one life to live and I can choose to do whatever I want with it. So I can choose to stay in Olympia and hang out here and play roller derby and ride my motorcycle and live life that way. Or if I choose to go to medical school, that'll be another path. And so given the choice, I feel like it's kind of an easy decision.
你知道，我经常想，我只有一生可以活，我可以选择用它做任何我想做的事。所以我可以选择留在奥林匹亚，呆在这里玩轮滑德比，骑摩托车，过那种生活。或者如果我选择去读医学院，那会是另一条路。所以既然有了选择，我觉得这是一个简单的决定。
If you do get to that next round, it's for keeps. You know, you're not going to be able to leave the planet. What if you get there and it sucks?
如果你真的进入了下一轮，那就是认真的。你知道，你将无法离开那个星球。如果到了那里发现很糟糕怎么办？
Yeah, that-- that would suck.  It probably will suck pretty-- like, it will suck, I'm sure. But you-- you get to know that your life is about something bigger than just, like, paying your bills and living and dying and being boring.
是的，那——那会很糟糕。那可能确实会很糟糕——我知道，它会很糟。但你——你会知道你的生活不仅仅是为了付账单、生活、死亡和无聊。
That story was produced by Elizabeth Jenkins for the podcast Love + Radio -- which, I have to say, has some of the most emotionally complicated stories and portraits of people that anybody is doing anywhere. It's on the Radiotopia network. I totally recommend it. This story was edited and mixed by Nick van der Kolk and Brendan Baker. You can find Love + Radio at loveandradio.org.
那个故事由伊丽莎白·詹金斯（Elizabeth Jenkins）为播客《Love + Radio》制作——我必须说，这是任何地方所能听到的最情绪化、最复杂的人物画像。它在 Radiotopia 网络上。我完全推荐它。这个故事由尼克·范·德·科尔克（Nick van der Kolk）和布伦丹·贝克（Brendan Baker）剪辑和混音。你可以在 loveandradio.org 找到《Love + Radio》。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from JP Dukes. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
好了，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、史蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。JP 杜克斯（JP Dukes）提供制作帮助。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。阿德里安·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。
Research help today from Benjamin Anastas and Michelle Harris. Music help from Rob Geddis. Special thanks to LaShante Goffigan.
今天本杰明·阿纳斯塔斯（Benjamin Anastas）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）提供了研究帮助。罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）提供了音乐帮助。特别感谢拉尚特·戈菲根（LaShante Goffigan）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. You know, I always thought of him as the general manager of a public radio station, but if you ask him, he see himself more like this.
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）。你知道，我一直以为他是公共广播电台的总经理，但如果你问他，他把自己看作是这样的人。
I'm a little girl running my own business.
我是一个经营自己生意的女孩。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "SPACE TRUCKIN'" BY DEEP PURPLE]
（音乐——Deep Purple 的《Space Truckin'》）